hey guys before we start this episode we
just want to thank him for sponsoring
this video they are a new men's wellness
brand that helps out with issues like
hair loss
edie and the acnes all over the face
yeah so make sure to check out the link
in the description so you can get your
own comprehensive hair kits for just $5
$5 right now check it out baby let's get
into the episode in unwanted touching
news oh don't touch me man
so bye love you Steve oh that's very
nice no I took it
she wants a random stranger to say yeah
it doesn't mean anything was from you
whatever when it's from people you care
about you could you hear it all the time
yeah just like preaching to the choir
bro it's like when you tell me that you
love me I'm like yeah I know I know yeah
I know
11 damn you lucky uh-huh it looks like I
love you from afar the CEO of the
company that owns look craw Spring
sparkling water all we treat that [ __ ]
don't we oh well we don't have any right
now and a fridge so we have we have you
know fresh meat I know you're talking
about the [ __ ] downtown LA just
kidding films office in the frigerator
where we have loads and loads of drinks
for anybody wow man
anytime you want you can walk in and
grab it it's like a convenience store
but you don't have to pay for any time
yep it's like an office I made me one
office that has free Google Google
Facebook Instagram but we're not even
that billion dude you said name me one
office it would give you five good name
like name me one middle size company
that gives free drinks all the time wait
so JK didn't pay for those huh you're
tricky small size oh me how about naima
small size company I can't barbell
Brigade you guys get free yes where
this is I pay for that protein shake no
our office I didn't say the gym I said
the office we're in the back next to
your refrigerator yeah you have an
office in Barbourville no barbell
brigade has an office in JK in the back
Oh duh oh that's funny I didn't even
know they had a refrigerator back there
I always forget though that's good
[ __ ] what about these unwanted
touches okay
the CEO of the company owns La Crosse
sparkling water make sure to let us know
if you have some or not Jude thank you
is being sued for allegedly groping two
male pilots oh [ __ ] yeah like for his
private plane I guess why could the
seals a homo I guess how do you know
they're male pilots they just say who
lets passengers [ __ ] go inside the
cockpit that's what you said private
plane it didn't even say private plane
no eyes the private plane Nicky said he
did it this is what I'm guessing yeah so
every time I go on the plane and an off
the plane the [ __ ] captain himself
makes it but he walks himself to the
gate I like to the [ __ ] doorway to
say hello and goodbye to every single
person I guarantee you when his
[ __ ] stood up
wait you're welcome you did a nut check
that could be but if you have a private
plane you can interact with the pilot as
much as you want you [ __ ] low-class
go wait for the common area to open know
what he should do is just hire escorts
to fly his plane escort pilots yeah like
you know some people they learn multiple
skill set so they can have multiple side
gigs and you just find one that is an
escort that is a pilot why can't I get
followed by a [ __ ] rich person what
is my problem like he's just gonna sue
man hey
feed you listen listen Lucy it's not
enough food or water can you love I need
more oh yeah so this is Lacroix or look
for what however yeah I do the same
thing it's a sexual innuendo man [ __ ]
dude
Barney Jackie legs just like that all
over the place really you're a gusher
man you jack with your laptop ragged
humbly so Nick caparelli CEO off this is
he looks like an actor Harry Potter I
was just gonna say he looks like Harry
Potter in It's a Wonderful Life
you know the you know the bad guy here
oh the but his name's Harry his name's
Harry Potter not just mr. Potter
eh Potter you think his name is Harry
the black and white movie yeah we're a
joke it's at wing every times that he's
trying to earn his wings but it's first
names Harry the little boy in the back
his name's Harry Potter that's some
old-ass [ __ ] it's a wonderfully yes man
my grandma's like [ __ ] making fun of
you right now cuz that's an old ass
movie I love that movie we watch it
every Christmas time it please watch it
yeah
please in the theater the Egyptian
theater and I don't think we're talking
about the same one little little kid
that's the concentration oh that's a
beautiful life that's not dude that's
not a Christmas movie
what you doing watching Moses every year
Christmas that's the [ __ ] honeymoon
movie yeah Wow I totally get it
yeah I guess anyway so Nick pepper ah
he's a billionaire CEO of a company
called the national beverage which owns
Lacroix and so apparently he has groped
two male pilots and now he's being sued
the first male pilot ended up settling
for an undisclosed amount and now the
second lawsuit is coming about I wonder
how he groped him well apparently he
said that he engaged in quote repeated
unjustified unwarranted and uninvited
grabbing rug
and groping of one of the pilots legs in
a sexual manner reaching up towards his
sexual organs
he's probably got really soft hands cuz
old guys they look really soft oh you're
not my wrinkly more like bony oh I
pictures I'm really dry for some yeah
really veiny and dry why are we trying
to figure out how it felt when they were
touched I understand cuz he's probably
imagining it to see if it's bad or not
if I'm imagining it yes what the [ __ ]
yeah I'm like if I'm wearing slacks
right and I have my white short sleeve
dress shirt tucked in right and I'm just
there like refilling the peanuts and
some guy is like slowly moving up my leg
I'm like I don't know if that's bad or
not anything goes wrong calm or even
like
yeah I don't know if I'll get mad and
sued because a young strong man I feel
like oh you're rough man be gentle dude
[Laughter]
but oh man I kind of feel like a tender
grandma died looks like not tender he
looks like he could like hold you down a
bit
he looks like a politician he looks like
he shakes your hand real it's like he
controlled the banking systems but his
face
looks like my testicle so that's what my
comparison is I like my balls and his
face remind me of my balls so why not
tankless do but his balls are old for
sure his balls look like the [ __ ]
ruffles chips no Richard everything on
his little [ __ ] body is nice and even
and brand-new you know like what the
[ __ ] are these recycles damn already got
the wrinkles huh
yeah and it's rough you did tell his
first girlfriend even as soon as she
comes over the smooth this little baby
but wrinkly ball
always what are they still that way
taking abuse elbow like baby balls I
don't know I don't that's the first
encounter I've added they've also
because I mean with my younger brothers
and with Isaac they're all the same
they're all old y'all are born with some
old ass part dark my god why even be
smoother now than they used to be they
are pretty smooth see I don't remember
balls until elementary school so what
happened yeah well that's when you first
found them yeah would hear us I don't
remember like even remembering like what
my balls look like so in your memory it
was just your [ __ ] dick that's it
yeah that's how small your balls are
yeah maybe looked like until like when
when did you first find out what your
vagina looked like because I always
thought it was just a slit until we had
health class in seventh grade and they
showed like a picture of it I was like
that's not what it looks like
and I gotta take a mirror it was like
banana you never down there yeah no idea
I thought that I take a mirror until way
later I was too scared I was like I
don't know I don't wanna oh it looked
crazy I was like I've never seen that
before
it's crazy to have a part of your body
that you can't see yeah like your
[ __ ] I don't know what a swell looks
like I don't either
I don't mean to I kind of do no I'm not
gonna say I'm ranting about them later
no you're not give me hurt Mary needs to
check his hair I need to check it out
you probably won't be able to see
anything with their freaking you always
call your seer check you probably have a
but see urgent - yes cut his hair with
his clippers like that and at one time
him his mom came home and his dad was
bent over in front of the the tall
mirror shaving his [ __ ] with dis
Clippers friend clippers with his sons
clippers yeah
then he always uses up here on this man
that's baby go back pop all those lucky
wife oh so when she's eating that but
it's really nice and similar exactly why
would you say why would why would it be
nice for the wife it doesn't do [ __ ] for
her cuz it looks as it's aesthetically
pleasing equals comics clean here like
flexion I'd be doing it yeah you [ __ ]
I never see Steve's but I don't [ __ ] em
come on come on all right anyway it
probably looks like I love it away from
me yeah I've never seen his butt exactly
show me your butt but I'm married to you
try the time when he walks out of this
[ __ ] room naked he walks out back well
he's never naked never
he's never Nagy's and never-nude he has
boxer briefs and you take David
Chappelle yeah he made a joke like that
when they do the wife swap yeah so then
the wife goes to a black guy and then
the the white guy wife goes to the black
guy but the white guy's gonna do the
black wife and then heat like he's
wearing his [ __ ] matching pajamas and
then he like she's like gonna get naked
and he's like no I'm just gonna stick it
out of the hole what depends right it's
too big for the hole so the underwear is
still on the thigh yeah show her your
butt you say my butt no look my my balls
like [ __ ] boom that's true he has
huge balls not welcome man
I've taken him out before but that's
good for you he's got big balls
yeah there Billy big so that's why I
keep them in there man
I gotta control them dude you have sex
with the jockstrap fun that's right
that's a good name I'm just curious
about a [ __ ] dick hole like I'm just
so curious I don't have that problem
I'll draw you a just do an incan no no
right yeah
[Music]